[Musique]
Christophe est chef étoilé aime écrire
des histoires faites de passion et
d'excellence en suivant le fil de la
Loire son aspiration la mené ici au cœur
de Blois non pas pour poser des étoiles
mais bien une fleur une fleur qui l'a
baptisé
fleur de Loire
lui c'est beau c'est poétique c'est du
Christophe fleur de Loire est un espace
de liberté qui l'invite chaque jour à
composer et créer avec ce que la nature
lui offre
[Musique]
bon là je pense qu'on va se mettre bien
on teste le canapé
ouh là là
[Musique]
il y a un sport
là on est dans le cœur en fait de fleur
de Loire et
Raphaël notre architecte en fait a créé
ces petites îles qu'on retrouve sur la
Loire qui s'appelle des grèves on
voulait pas un jardin qui soit précis
carré tu vois on voulait vraiment
retrouver cet esprit un peu sauvage
devant fleur de Loire allez viens je
t'emmène dans macérat agrumes là bas
j'ai une petite collection tu vas voir
Raphaël ce lieu on monte le doigt en
fait ah là on est dans une serre qui a
été créé spécialement pour pour le chef
et pour bien bichonner ses agrumes tous
ces citronniers orangés moins de Bouddha
on y trouve quoi Christophe ici tu sais
quoi on a 17 variétés différentes tu as
des citrons caviar ça c'est des yuzu
là-bas on a un Maxime accord soit il y a
vraiment une beaucoup beaucoup de choses
ça c'est magnifique ça c'est une feuille
de combat sans ça
à la maison
pourquoi tu fais semblant je te vois toi
la maison tu as fait ça tu peux pas
sentir à la télé c'est fou mais moi je
c'est incroyable on leur Raphaël ton
aspiration tu la cuisse où c'est la
Loire un autre premier inspiration ici
on est dans un site exceptionnel donc le
sujet ça a pas été de recréer un jardin
historique qui aurait été un pastiche
mais plutôt de faire rentrer la Loire
dans le jardin c'est un jardin d'Ille
les méandres dans lequel on déambule
entre des prairies avec beaucoup de
végétations spontanées qui vont évoluer
tout au long de l'année et puis pouvoir
dialoguer avec ce paysage de Loire juste
en face
alors forcément je suis dans ton potager
je dois toutes ces fleurs explique-moi
un petit peu les origines de fleurs de
Loire tout simplement fleur de Loire en
l'occurrence c'est vraiment le fait de
se retrouver
à fleur de loi tu vois vraiment en
surface de la Loire je sais pas si tu as
vu mais le bâtiment surplombe ce fleuve
qui est magnifique et c'est vrai quand
on s'est penché à essayer de trouver un
nom finalement fleur de Loire ça collait
exactement à la bâtisse on est sur
combien d'hectares ici un hectare et
demi de culture 3000 m² de serre on va
aménager là-bas au fond un petit verger
avec des variétés anciennes de pommes et
de poire écoute merci Christophe pour
cette promenade par contre il y a moyen
que je profite un petit peu du spa là
moi je vais retourner en cuisine par
contre toi ce serait bien que tu bosses
un petit peu au jardin là
oui parce que là ils ont besoin de toi
mais oui c'est lui c'est lui vas-y
non non